ans tandis que martine aubry ségolène
royal se rencontraient hier rue de
solférino jean luc mélenchon lors d'un
meeting à saint denis a lancé son parti
de gauche
wehrling aurel il varie lui même étonné
jean luc mélenchon hier plus de 1500
personnes ont fait le déplacement pour
le meeting de lancement de son parti de
gauche est sonné et constante
je devrai à 23 semaines qu'il a claqué
la porte du ps un parti trop libérale à
son goût son modèle oskar lafontaine en
délicatesse avec le spd allemand
il a fondé son propre parti de gauche a
en allemagne vous avez l'autre exemple
nous étions aussi une partie un parti
nouveau et nous avons succès nous avons
après les sondages mais de là environ
12% et tout le monde et nous changeons
la politique allemande et jean luc
mélenchon n'a pas de mots assez forts
pour critiquer la politique de la droite
mais surtout il tend la main aux
communistes aux écologistes et aux
trotskistes
bref à tous les partis à la gauche du ps
nous sommes tous des socialistes nous
sommes tous des communistes
nous sommes tous des écologistes des 36
mn des libertaires à notre manière nous
sommes plus là nous sommes des
républicains avec passion premier
objectif les élections européennes
les discussions sont déjà bien entamées
avec le parti communiste de marie-george
buffet pour constituer des listes
communes
rendez vous est pris avec olivier
besancenot à peine de lancer le parti de
gauche est sur tous les fronts
la crise et koné